this is the home of guar as she is a
licensed matchmaker I did promise
sona's grandmother that I would try to
find her and Armenian groom you're not
happy about this are you I'm not happy
about it I'm not excited or to it okay
all right we'll just settle down it's
not all about what you want a psyche
about that guy this is a guy I think
this is a guy with a job
he's clearly on the Sopranos is a
provider he can provide many cooked
meats
oh that's not a problem
she likes young man I like that you
clearly he he went to Harvard oh those
shorts are a problem
looked like he had bottles of whiteout
in his pocket and exploited what
happened what is what's happening here
that's auto-erotic asphyxiation I think
he's choking himself for sexual pleasure
what glad you can understand me yeah
yeah I know what that business is okay
oh you know what I could see you with
him yes I'm basically looking for a nice
girl but 17 years old 21 oh wow I'm Way
over is cut up that's terrible
women like great wine improve with age
is what I've always said yes dottie no
no Bobby Lee love : but then if you keep
the wine too long the wine starts to
turn sour so you want to have the wine
at the right time it doesn't keep
getting better the wine 34 really goes
south after a while just if you don't
refrigerated his favorite blue tarp now
he knew you married at Target
package do you look at that he's taking
it from his crotch that's okay that's it
a reverse dick pic look at that it's got
no sleeves are you okay with the no
sleeves thing sure he works out
oh he's showing off the guns I don't
know in case I want to bring a friend
friend go see his gun show now I'm
actually thinking about like an actual
gun show but I would never go to write
this whole thing fell apart yeah well
that's good that shows that he likes
nature or maybe he's [ __ ] I don't
know who takes a picture himself
[ __ ] in the woods you know what you
know why the divorce happened because he
stops and poops wherever here I'm
cracking myself up it's like I love you
honey well time to go
anything squash there bring it because
[Laughter]
you showed us many pictures of many men
most of them in jail or with wooden
limbs but they there was no match was
there we are here for two more days
I think Sona would be easy to find a
match for very beautiful good good job
in America well thank you for thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography